This morning
authorities in
California are also including
more than 100 National Guard mem
as they are searching for five y
old Kyle Dolan.
He was clinging to his mother
before he was swept away.
As those floodwaters
overwhelmed their SUV
on the way to school.
His mother is speaking out
and it's heart wrenching
I want to switch places with Kyl
I don't want to be here.
I want Kyle to be here.
I wish Kyle was the one that was
Camilla Bernal is live for CNN
this morning in California.
We're also hearing from Kyle's f
I know the family is obviously s
with this as they are
having these search efforts unde
What are you hearing
Hey, Kaitlin, the father telling
he's in shock,
that this is so difficult to pro
but that they will search
until they find Kyle that search
incredibly difficult
because they're looking in this
You can see
and you can hear that
the water is still flowing
very rapidly, just a few feet up
the creek. Is that car?
You can't see it
because it is just so dark
despite all of these conditions.
The family saying they are not g
I just want him back
when the water rose.
Five year
old Kyle Doan sounded calm His f
recounting the boy's
last words to his mother.
He was telling her, mommy, don't
It's okay.
Everything will care.
But the father says the water ri
Kyle away
from his mother's arms on Monday
as she was getting out
and trying to hold him.
The current
was there and it took him.
Her screams heard by nearby resi
who did everything they could to
And then and was able
to get a rope to her
and get her over to the side
where they could get to my son.
The husband that was there saw h
He was floating back
his head was above water.
He was looking out.
And that
was the last time they saw him.
Now, shock
denial and heartbreak.
My wife really it's hard
because she survived
the the event and he's not here
and she feels really guilty
that she wasn't the one
to go down, not him.
She did not want to eat.
She refused.
She said, if I had my sons out t
I don't want to eat either.
A grainy home
video from a Christmas past.
Now a treasured memory.
Big one. Big one.
He was a good kid.
He had lots of friends
and he liked to help the teacher
I mean, he was a kindergartner
and he was doing new experiences
And he's probably like a lot of
you know,
when you're in your neighborhood
But the family is determined
to find Kyle.
His older brother, Tyler,
searching with the help of frien
and for the first time Wednesday
his mother's car.
I'm I'm just speechless from
seeing that
kind of just a rush of emotions
Just a lot going on right now
as he looks for his little broth
He's reminded of the joy
he brought to the family.
His buddy.
He wakes up the whole family
every single morning.
Most of us had just been tried t
and he's the one who gets us out
every single day.
And an entire community
searching, hoping, praying.
Do you want to find him?
You want him found that
you don't want to be the one to
And
yeah, you just.
It's scary. It's scary.
But we just want to found
it's that help and support
that the family says
is giving them strength.
It's been tough giving.
Very good. A lot of giving
a lot of support, a lot of frien
trying to balance hope of Kyle
smiling face.
Against the grim reality.
It's going to be hard at some po
It's going to be really hard.
And the father
telling me that he understands
this may be a recovery operation
Nonetheless,
that search,
Kaitlin resumes when the sun com
Yeah, we're keeping them in line
Millburn. All Thank you.